okay so this presentation is gonna be on
the five senses sight smell taste sound
and touch our senses are obviously
relate related to our nervous system
which we talked about in a previous
video so we're gonna be mentioning the
word impulses and action potentials if
you don't remember what those are check
out the other video or come and see me
before or after school and I'd be happy
to review that with you so let's go
ahead and get into the sentences so
let's begin with the the sense of sight
so let's look at the anatomy of an eye
first of all let's start from the
outside and work our way in so the outer
covering the outer protective layer of
the eye is simply called the cornea it's
clear and allows light to pass through
of course and when we move on in we come
to the colored part of the eye called
the iris the iris is a muscle and so
like any muscle it's able to stretch and
contract the iris happens to stretch and
contract whenever there is an abundant
or a small amount of light present so
you might have noticed if you ever stare
into somebody's eyes the little hole in
their eye their pupil which we'll talk
about in a minute the pupil will get
bigger and smaller based on the amount
of light that's in the room well that's
because of the iris when it's dark
the iris will stretch open that way
whatever light is in the room can
hopefully enter your eye and you can see
better but in a bright room the iris
will not close completely shut but will
shrink and well I don't know shrink
upside the iris will will lengthen or
lengthen to make the pupil really really
small so not a lot of light can pass
through and so the pupil and the iris
are most definitely related to one
another the action of the iris will
adjust the size
the pupil but one thing to mention the
pupil is not really an object it's a
hole it's a hole in the middle of an
iris like if you have a doughnut the
hole is not actually part of the
doughnut there's nothing there it's just
empty space that's really what the
people is but again the pupil and the
iris are and that are have a
relationship to one with one another
because the iris will control the size
of the pupil as I mentioned the hole is
called the pupil and the hole will be
bigger in dim light oh that's because
the iris the iris will will open nice
and will stretch in and make the pupil
bigger if it's really really dark out
but the opposite happens in bright light
the iris will kind of close up and so
therefore the whole the pupil shrinks in
bright light well just behind just
behind the pupil just behind the iris we
have the lens and so if you notice in
this picture here the lens kind of looks
like the shape of a football and so it
sits behind the iris and when light
enters the eye light passes through the
cornea through the pupil and through the
lens the lens acts like a magnifier and
so when light passes through the lens
the light is magnified and you're able
to see objects a little bigger so the
lens acts as a magnifier it also helps
to focus light onto the back of the eye
which we'll learn is called the retina
so as light enters the pupil it passes
the lens and in this diagram here the
what what looks like empty space in the
middle of the eye it's not actually
empty space this it's filled with a with
a gel a watery gel that has nutrients in
it which will supply the eyeball and all
the cells of the eyeball with much
needed new
in water and this is called the vitreous
the vitreous gel and the vitreous gel is
also light I'm sorry is also clear the
vitreous gel is also clear so lights can
pass through it if the vitreous gel were
all cloudy that would impair your vision
and finally we come to near the back of
the eye we have a layer of cells called
the retina and what's so important about
these cells is the retina is the cells
that actually allow you to detect vision
so they're at the back of the eye and
light will enter the eye light will pass
the cornea passed past the pupil pass
the lens pass through the vitreous gel
and light will strike to the back of the
eye called the retina and the retina
there are two types of nerve cells there
are rad cells and cone cells and you may
remember that cone cells detect color
rod cells detect light and dark so what
the retina will do the retina will
create an impulse an action potential
and the action potential or the impulse
will then travel from the retina up the
optic nerve the optic nerve leads into
your brain and your brain will interpret
that impulse as vision so we're going to
go through the site process and a little
more detail on the next the next slide
so the process of vision here we have
the same diagram with all the parts
labeled so step one in this process
light will pass through a pass into our
eye pass through the cornea and through
the pupil so let's just say it's an
average day out not too sunny not too
dark and so the pupil is open enough for
light to pass through and then when
light passes through the pupil the lens
will focus light onto the back of the
eye the area known as the retina so not
only does the lens focus the light I
also mentioned earlier that the lens
acts as a magnifier so it'll magnify the
images that we're seeing
and finally we're not finally sorry at
the back of the eye we have the retina
and we mentioned that there are rad
cells and cone cells on the retina rod
and cone cells are examples of
photoreceptors because they detect light
and so in our animation here step number
three we have an action potential and
impulse being created well once the
retina creates the impulse that impulse
will travel up the optic nerve and up
the optic nerve which leads directly
into our brain and our brain will
interpret that as vision
you
so here's a fun little test you can do
behind the blue box on the Left I'm
gonna remove the blue box I want you to
tell me the color of the words that you
see so from top to bottom they'll be
about eight words read them from top to
bottom read the color that you see don't
read the actual word read the color here
we go I'm going to remove the box in
three two one
that should have been really easy
because the color blue matched the
actual blue text the word yellow is
actually written in yellow letters the
word red is written in red letters but
now we're going to do what's called the
Stroop effect it's a little fun to the
fun way that we can trick our brain I
want you to do the same thing don't read
the word don't read the word read the
color read the color that the word is
printed in read it from top to bottom
here we go three two one
it's a lot more difficult isn't it just
because the color of the text that
doesn't match to the actual word it's a
little tricky on our brain there's all
little tricks that you can do to kind of
mess with your brain a little bit and
kind of mess with the impulses that are
being sent to your brain this one is
called the Stroop effect so let's move
on and talk about our sense of hearing
well let's look at the anatomy of an ear
first of all the fleshy outer part of
the ear the part that people will
decorate by piercings is called the
pinna
and it's the outer part of the ear and
it's shaped like a funnel so what what
happens with it when sound enters the
pinna the pinna funnels the sound into
your ear canal so the pinna is not
simply just for decoration purposes it
actually has a role to play it's the
outer part of your ear and it helps to
funnel funnel sound waves into your ear
canal
follow the diagram we come that enters
through the pin ER and we lead into the
ear canal and we come to the eardrum the
eardrum is a fleshy layer of tissue and
the eardrum will vibrate whenever a
sound enters your ear and right behind
the eardrum are the three of the
smallest bones in the human body the
incus the malleus and the stapes and so
these are three bones that will help to
amplify the sound so you can hear it
nice and clearly and behind those three
bones that incus the malleus and the
stay piece is a curly seashell shaped
bone called the cochlea so the inside of
the cochlea there's a fluid and we'll
talk about that fluid more in a minute
inside the cochlea there's a fluid and
there are also what are called
mechanoreceptors Meccano
is simply a prefix that means pressure
our pressure sensors pressure receptors
inside the cochlea these pressure
sensors these mechanoreceptors are what
will detect sound they'll create an
impulse and they'll send the impulse
into your brain we'll go into that a
little more detail on the next slide
so here we have sound transmission so
what happens is sound waves which are
simply vibrations of the air will enter
your ear canal in this animation
somebody's listening to music so the
sound wave from the music enters your
ear canal in area 2 of the picture we
can see the eardrum and those 3 bones
the incus the malleus and the stay piece
begin to vibrate so the sound waves
cause the eardrums the eardrum and the
end the three bones the incas animales
and the stay piece to vibrate that
vibration is passed on to area 3 and 4
of the picture the pearly bone in the
back of your ear called the cochlea so
sound will enter the Pinner be directed
to the ear canal vibrate the eardrum and
the incus the malleus and the staties
that will cause the cochlea to vibrate
that's what's happening in area 3 and 4
in the diagram the cochlea is vibrating
and inside of the cochlea is a fluid
what happens is when the cochlea begins
to vibrate that fluid begins to move and
slush around and so what happens is as
that fluid moves the fluid causes cells
called hair cells to bend so the motion
of the fluid in the cochlea causes what
are called hair cells to bend that
bending process creates an impulse which
will see an area number 5 so here's a
look at a picture of those hair cells
see how they have little cilia sticking
straight up into the air well when when
fluid rushes over these hair cells they
Bend and when they Bend it creates an
impulse so if we come back to our
diagram here in area number 5 we have an
impulse being created inside of the
cochlea inside of those Meccano
receptors that we
in the moment ago the impulse will
travel for up the what's called the
auditory nerve the auditory nerve picks
up audio sound so the impulse travels up
the auditory nerve and directly into
your brain and your brain will interpret
that impulse as sound in this case
hopefully good sounding music
you
well let's write let's go over our sense
of smell and our sense of taste
all in one slide because you might know
that your sense of smell and sense of
taste art are related to one another
let's start off with our nose so what we
have here is a person inhaling inhaling
blue circles through their nose these
blue circles are simply scent molecules
if someone sprays perfume in the room
then those blue molecules would be the
perfume molecules what happens is when
you inhale them those molecules dissolve
in the mucus in your nose and what
happens then is those molecules cause
impulses to be created you have chemical
sensors in your nose called chemo
receptors the chemo receptors will
detect the chemicals in that you smell
the chemicals will dissolve in the mucus
in your nose and that will activate an
impulse to be created by those chemical
receptors so here we have an impulse
traveling up what's called your
olfactory nerve those little dark
branches in the picture those aren't
nose hairs
those are nerves and so when those scent
molecules dissolved in the mucus those
nerves created an impulse the impulse
travels up the olfactory nerve into our
brain and our brain will interpret that
impulse as a pleasant aroma let's look
at the sense of taste on the right here
we have a course a picture of a tongue
there are as our tongue is of course
covered with saliva and it's also
covered I'm sure you know with objects
called taste buds so how do we sense
taste
well let's zoom on in and take a closer
look here's some microscopically zoom
didn't taste buds and kind of here's an
artist's drawing of a taste bud when we
eat
here we have these molecules
representing food so these molecules are
were in a bite of our food let's say
that this is these are salty molecules
right here - salty molecules from our
food dissolve in our saliva the taste
buds will then there they go they just
dissolved in our saliva the taste bud
has what are called chemo receptors on
it again chemo receptors means chemical
receptors the taste buds have chemical
receptors which will detect the salty
chemicals in the food or they might
detect the savory chemicals or they
might detect the bitter chemicals and
ultimately the taste buds will create
the chemo receptors will create an
impulse the impulse travels this is
actually called your cranial nerve up
your cranial nerve and into your brain
you
in our last sense is the sense of touch
we have all over our skin various types
of receptors Meccano receptors are just
one type of receptors that we have
Meccano is a prefix that means pressure
you know we have pressure sensors on our
skin that someone touches you you can
feel the pressure of their touch if you
look in the picture you can see that
near the surface of the skin in the
upper layers we have sensors to detect
gentle touches deeper into the skin you
can see in the bottom right hand corner
we have sensors to detect strong
pressure here we have an insect flying
around and landing on our skin well
we've all had insects crawl on our skin
before and it kind of tickles the reason
it tickles is look in the animation when
the fly is crawling around on our skin
it causes our arm hair to wiggle look
what's wrapped around the base of our
hair there are nerves wrapped around the
base of our hair those nerves will
create an impulse leads to our brain as
I mentioned low in the lower level
levels of the skin we have heavy
pressure sensors you can see some heavy
strong pressure sensors in the lower
right hand corner watch this this is
kind of a morbid animation watch this oh
no we have a knife coming and stabbing a
person into the arm
well that stabbing process activated
strong pressure sensors deep within the
arm that will send a pain signal to the
person's brain now there's a good chance
the stabbing might also destroy the
pressure sensors but in this case we're
we're just gonna say that the person was
temporarily hurt and eventually they'll
heal and the stabbing wasn't too serious
well if you notice we have thermo
receptors all over our skin thermo
receptive receptors detect hot and cold
and you know that if someone comes up
and puts an ice cube on the back of your
neck you can feel feel it instantly if
someone comes and touches you with
something hot or if you accidentally
touch something hot you feel it almost
instantly we have pain receptors all
over our skin
if you've ever stubbed your toe if you
ever drop something on your hand if
you've ever had a paper cut you can see
the pain sensors are just beneath the
surface of their skin
that's why pain cuts hurts or paper cuts
that's why paper cuts hurt so badly is
because paper cuts
activate pain sensors that are located
just underneath the surface of the skin
even though a paper cut is fairly mild
can cause a lot of pain for that reason
and so the big thing I want you of
course to see is that these sensors will
send impulses to your brain so you bring
it's impulses all the time watching
these notes think about the impulses
that are going on as you watch these
notes you have the visual you have light
entering your eyes so your eyes are
sending visual impulses to your brain
your herring my words right now so your
ears are sending auditory impulses to
your brain maybe maybe you can feel the
pencil in your hand
well that's because you have pressure
sensors in your skin in your fingers
that allow you to feel the pencil that's
in your head and so maybe you're chewing
on gum right now if you chew a nun gum
right now you have chemical sensors on
your tongue to detect taste and so we
have all these senses that are going
into our brain and being monitored daily
instantly from the moment we wake up
till the moment we go to bed and I take
that bag actually from the
were born until the day that we die
you
here we have we finally reached the end
here we have a practice quiz so yeah
what I would recommend is try pausing
this video and spend a few minutes to
try to answer these questions all of
these can be answered by by reviewing
the PowerPoint or viewing view of the
video so pause it try to work out these
questions I'd be happy to check your
answers before or after school so write
your answers out us up a piece of paper
if you like bring them to me after class
and I'd be happy to check them for
accuracy good luck